esta vez es este hospital de oklahoma
que fue el objetivo de una nueva matanza
el miércoles por la tarde la policía
intervino tras haber sido informada de
la presencia de un hombre armado cerca
del hospital son francis en tulsa las
numerosas fuerzas llegaron rápidamente
en el lugar pero ya era demasiado tarde
los agentes de policía entraron en el
edificio escucharon disparos y eso los
dirigió al segundo piso hasta ahora hay
cuatro civiles muertos el tirador está
muerto y creemos que se quitó la vida
el sospechoso sería un hombre de unos 40
años armado con un rifle y un arma de
fuego corta según la policía la
intervención rápida evitó un mayor
número de víctimas pero la matanza ha
vuelto a reavivar el debate sobre las
armas en eeuu una semana después de la
tragedia que dejó 21 muertos entre ellos
19 niños en una escuela de texas y menos
de un mes después de la matanza racista
de búfalo a buscarme en soledad iba de
camino al médico tenía a mis nietos
conmigo y se produjo esta horrible
escena es horrible es muy triste mi
nuera es de búfalo y ahora está tan
cerca de mi casa ya no es seguro salir a
la canarias
la reforma de la obtención de armas fue
una promesa de campaña del presidente
bailén pero hasta ahora sigue siendo un
gran fracaso político